it's not
we're gonna have some words it's not
about the size of the crowd it's the
angle you photograph it from
[Music]
I know it's a drinking show but I
consider it to be very wholesome very
family friendly sometimes we will have
non-alcoholic beverages sometimes we
will even have children's books
before we get to my very special guest
with his very special children's book
you need to get this game yes or no
you get to watch it you participate
virtually you can participate in real
life in the flesh if you go to
dailywire.com shop we did an initial run
of this we seriously underestimated how
many of you would want to host a
drinking game in your home we are
selling out very quickly of the
pre-order so go to dailymire.com shop
play the yes or no game with your loved
ones in the flesh I have one of my loved
ones in the flesh that would be
Sean Spicer Sean I was hoping it was me
[Applause]
where's my loved one
of your you are here
I'm so glad that you're here in person
you have brought me your new children's
book yes the parrots Go Bananas it's uh
targeted towards children four to twelve
and you're just outside the age range
but close enough I have the maturity
yeah well that's someone under four yeah
it's all about it's how old you act and
think and identify we're good or you
know so and plus I think a lot of
reporters can benefit from it so it's
about fake news I I there's a wide range
it's not just what's on the label that's
that's we also specialize around these
parts of children's books that can be
appreciated for adults as well I'm also
glad finally we have another mackerel
snapping paper stun during Lent
I've decided that's the first time ever
in my whole life I've decided not to
drink oh this is a first for you this is
the first ever and it's actually it's
not as hard as I thought I don't have
the shakes 24 hours a day but you now
also have a fruity looking non-alcoholic
beverage yeah so I've done it for uh
about over actually over 30 years really
every time at lent yeah really yeah uh
actually yeah so it's been over 30 years
one do you know one time for Atlanta I
actually gave up these fruity
non-alcoholic Beverages and it was
almost harder because during the day I'm
you I don't yeah I don't usually start
with an eye-opener of whiskey in the
morning or something yeah but that's
that's very impressive so you know
you're not an alcoholic no I know that I
can do like 40 whatever you know
counting Sundays it's like 45 days right
right I'm not really sure that that's
the medical definition of that but well
that's what I'm going with okay I'll
I'll subscribe to that so usually if
there's a woman on the show she will go
first you're a man so I will go first
Shall We Begin we shall
scaramucci is a Fed
I'm going to say that you would say yes
because
he was clearly an agent of the federal
government for 11 days
for a lot of reasons I'm going to say no
I actually I I
think a lot enough of you that I think
that you would say no as well yeah yeah
I I I I agree I would say no
uh
he burned bright he burned hot
and then he was out of the White House I
just don't know that the feds I think
that there's a standard
uh
I'll leave it at that this is very
diplomatic thank you it's like your
pocket it's like yeah we'll have you
back after Easter you can you can go
more into detail I'm gonna drink anyway
yeah
whatever this fruity concoction is it's
very enjoyable uh so now you go yes
it's true what they say about the United
States Navy Reserves
is they Winston Churchill is they well
okay I'll just answer
I know this is I I just I'm trying to
get inside of your head right now
but let me know if you succeed I I know
there's something preventing that
um
my apologies my apologies
did I get it right
uh no I I thought that you were gonna
guess yes but I didn't see this is the
hardest part is that I didn't know I
didn't have any presumptions so it was a
flip of the coin to be fair and I
equally went with the coin flip so you
know what Winston Churchill said about
the Navy
sure
now I don't know does that apply to the
that's why I was saying this doesn't
apply to the reserve the reserve that's
why I was a little that's this is where
I think your team was throwing there's
so many layers yeah that's why I was
like I don't the curveball with a Twist
do you think what do you think what
Churchill said about the Navy is true
just generally he's a truth teller
teller bet all three rum sodomy and the
Lash there's yeah I believe it is yours
sir
two questions in I'm very concerned
about yeah um the writer yeah I I've I
had those concerns they were affirmed
and yeah we keep Mr Davies around I'm
just wondering what sites he's searching
I hope he uses expressvpn yeah no I'm
just hoping that it's a it's not a daily
wire computer
this explains a lot of the spam you guys
are getting there's definitely uh Mr
Davies is there something you want to
tell us
okay
Dancing with the Stars in woke Hollywood
is like wrapping your toes in bacon and
playing footsie with a tiger
it's very dangerous
okay what would you say huh
[Music]
you answered correctly for me
you answered correctly from me
you seem to
you've seem to dance very well well
that's a lie no then you didn't watch
the show
um I also think relatively I think that
if you would if we had played this game
prior to being on the show I might have
answered differently I enjoyed the
experience thoroughly yeah
um and so therefore uh what I would have
thought of my experience before going on
versus after very different yeah uh I
enjoyed it and I enjoyed all of the
people that I interacted with so I
didn't I you did seem to get on well
with I I did sort of wonder when it was
announced you know that what what
problem I have that yes you know yes
whether the medications
call your doctor and yeah but no you
seem to get on pretty well with them I I
did I loved it and I think I went in
eyes wide open and that was the thing
and I also think look that negotiation
um was three years in the running and I
don't mean it wasn't like but but my
point is that I developed some
relationships where there was a a back
and forth where I felt confident that
this was not a you know like a setup
that there were people who generally
thought hey this could be a fun
experience and you know we've got to
know each other and I thought okay well
this isn't going to go that bad yeah
yeah okay all right
it's not God
it
we're gonna have some words with Mr
Davies it's not about the size of the
crowd it's the angle you photograph it
from
oh
um
how would you answer
correct
incorrect I think that you can make the
perception does make a difference you
can
okay so but
nevertheless would you not argue as I
would if you argue this I would defend
you as arguing this thank you it was the
largest crowd ever okay if you just I'm
talking about the numbers of eyeballs on
the inauguration it was the largest one
ever God I'm I I this is uh this is
probably the most litigated thing that
I've had to deal with uh and and
unfortunately we don't have the hours
necessary to but but I look I I've made
the case in the thing I mean the the
quick version of this yeah is the the
the goal at that at that day was to
basically say kind of what you're saying
which is it wasn't just about if you
actually look at the words it wasn't
about just saying hey here's the number
of people in the National Mall it was
about the audience I was meeting and
there were people that were watching it
online they were there were frankly
technologically uh technological
advances that didn't occur right during
the Obama or the George Washington or
Abe Lincoln years right so therefore you
could stream things
um on platforms that didn't exist
therefore I thought it was pretty safe
and and therefore right if we're talking
about the audience for my show in the
room it is at most one person we're
talking about the audience for my show
digitally it's at least four or five
yeah okay so we're talking about the
majority of my show is online you're
gonna tell me that's not the audience uh
that was such a bogus attack on you well
yeah I I don't I will say that there
might not have been the most Artful
delivery uh but I but thank you as
someone who's occasionally been attacked
in the press for
I you know the funny thing is I think
I'm pretty sure I did come across
something it was yeah it was I don't I
couldn't even remember the topic now but
but you know the libs will what they
will do is they try to find they'll go
word for word even if your words are
precisely perfectly right they will they
will either present them in a way that
is the least charitable way possible or
they'll just rewrite them right but it's
also the funny thing is I I love how
they'll take what you're saying and make
it it assume the worst right for lack of
a better way to put this but when
someone on the left says they'll go well
you know what they meant was and I'm
like wait a second oh this is insane I
mean it was funny my first book I was I
had this
fact check that I was talking about and
I quoted Mike Pence he was referring to
this jobs report and he said you know
more Americans are working now than ever
before it was statistically true like
let's call it 200 000 200 million people
were working whatever it was and he so
he said that the Washington Post fact
Checker came out and said it lacked
context because when you looked at it
proportionally to the size of the U.S
and I was like he literally said a true
thing but then they went in and said but
he lacked context because of the
proportion of our overall population I'm
like yeah you've got to be kidding me
but if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor well listen I know if you
when you really parse what he was really
meaning right and I took the Amtrak and
snowball said this or Corn Pop water I
mean like there are literal like I got
shot at here and Mandela took me out of
jail I mean like those are yeah those
are like literally not true things my
son I didn't talk to him about his
business associates I mean none of that
stuff this couldn't this might not be my
laptop none of that stuff you know
forget about the context he's probably
telling the truth and you know everyone
talks about Corn Pop but snowball that's
he was the real capodic and also He's
The Mastermind
he gets like he gets off all the time
yeah Elon Musk is at the very least on
to something when he tweeted aliens
built the pyramids of referencing the
Great Pyramid of Giza I actually have
very strong thoughts on this recent
recently strong thoughts is that because
and I'm just I wanted I know just so I
understand the context before I answer
is that because the Giza sheets uh are
from there the soft yeah not explainable
if it's merely a product of humans okay
because I I just wanna this helps me
answer
I'm going in with yes yes I say yes as
well okay
you were correct
then you are correct I I this one I yeah
my my thought though is
I'm getting thirsty so I need to you you
got to get something wrong my thought is
it's not aliens because aliens aren't
real but he's on to something in that
when most people talk about aliens I
think they're talking about demons
sightings or just their imagination the
libs can't make sense of demons because
they don't have much of a sense of the
spiritual world so it has to be a
physical oh see you're actually see I
was just thinking Does Elon think that
more than is it well he thinks it but I
think he's on to something oh see that
was because I actually
was answering it in the context of do
you think he thinks that do you think
he's on to something uh I don't I really
hadn't thought that much about it as
much as I think that like he's kind of
thinking kind of that so here's what I
wonder is when they were building the
pyramids
and they say hello how on Earth did they
do this
I don't want to seem like the guy in the
History Channel who attributes it demons
I think they worshiped demons and I
think demons play all sorts of little
tricks and they're very smart they're
nothing compared to God but you know
they do work little tricks in the world
increasingly you're seeing a cult
practices or people are are becoming
reacquainted with this idea and if you
told me
that there was weird demon stuff going
on in these ancient Pagan cultures
I wouldn't be surprised I'm going to
spend a lot more time on the internet
your Wikipedia Rabbit Hole this evening
is going to be ours yes I'm going down
this one I think there's strong evidence
for it you let me know let me know
obviously it'll be after the game uh
you're wrong okay
white hate is now more widely accepted
than the 2020 election results
[Laughter]
I'm not hesitating
okay you're right I was I was trying to
Barse double and triple negatives here
and all sort of Oh no you're right
straight up it's you're right it's
obviously it's not only accepted I mean
it's
right taught in schools yeah yeah yeah
this shouldn't be yeah
Mr Davies there clearly got bored and
was like I honestly just give me a
gimmick I was going to think if there
were any no but you're right I've run
out of stuff you're right right yeah it
is this is what making me wonder what's
next because right now
it is I know I wonder maybe there is
something I was going to say well
there's we knew that you you weren't
drinking for Lent but we figured okay at
least a little ketamine you know angel
dust it doesn't it's fine yeah okay
the most entertaining press secretary
from the past 15 years is sitting at
this table
what you would answer and what I would
answer um
entertaining of the last 15 years so
oh
you got that right
would you I'm trying to
see how charitable you would be to some
of the people who have come before and
after you uh
you're right so who is it it's kgp
himself obviously yeah obviously yeah
yeah I think that could have been an
easy out just saying except for yeah she
that would have made it a little more
challenging
um but that's a gimme it's a gimme it it
there have been colorful press
secretaries in the past and you you were
entertaining and that you brought a lot
of personality to the role but you were
not entertaining in the way that kgp is
entertaining I think part of it is is
that
there's days when you're like it's like
what time does this briefing end and
she's like look we've read the briefings
to the brief that Congress has briefed
us on and you're like but lady I'm just
asking you for a time
well we're gonna have to get back and
and so as I've said before look I said
look before and the we've looked at
looking and okay
you're and I'm like no no I have no
follow-up I have no follow-up to that so
that you're right yeah unfortunately we
no we agree sad to say
your average Democrat voter would be
totally fine by the way I do love
Democrat voter yeah it just needles no
ick no I I don't I do detention every
one of those times where like when they
you know every time when I was at the
RNC they would say like can you please
not do that oh definitely I'll double
down I I have to because it's one I I
learned this I wrote a column in college
good and the editor was a big lib you
know and and but he but he knew that he
that I like to punch these things up and
irritate all the libs on campus and he
goes Michael you missed something you
made a huge mistake
you wrote Democratic party it's like hey
you're thank you for having my best
interests here you're right never again
that's I yeah um so there you go okay
your average Democrat voter would be
totally fine letting Hunter Biden teach
their kids
in public school
um
I'm gonna say you would say yes you're
you're right though I would say no I
would say no you would say no yeah okay
and I'll tell you why because I think
that there is a big difference between
the average Democratic voter
I still think that that's 55 right so if
we take average right that there's still
a little bit interesting so I I think
there's a big difference between the
loudest voices in the Democratic party
um the ones that we see on Twitter the
ones we hear in Congress and the ones
that are on television versus the ones
that you still walk down the street and
they say I'm a democratic vote I think
it's becoming increasingly smaller but
that average is probably still just over
I mean it's becoming in two years or
three years I I might have to vote
differently but for now it's still over
that 50 Mark so you you were approaching
it from analyzing the the data on the
voter side I was taking it from the
hunter side and I just thought well
Hunter Biden's a straight white male
there's no way they would be fine with
that he's a degenerate but you know he's
yeah no you make a great point I think
you're you're probably right about that
even just when you think of Voters right
voters skew older a little more
responsible usually yeah yeah so that's
why because I just thought that the
average I think if you were talking
about like the people on Twitter they
would be like oh of course what's wrong
he's great like he could talk about
Redemption and painting uh and the
little bubbles or whatever the little
circle relationship advice
and you know um coping I mean like
there's a lot of but I don't see
the average I still think you can walk
down the street in a lot of communities
and they'd be like you know so yeah I
think I think you're right that's very
fair and charitable uh that's you it's
me yeah see what happens with it you
know after a few of these yeah
I know a little bit of watermelon
in the long run it's more dangerous to
send your child to public school than it
is to let them travel abroad in the
Middle East for a year at the age of 17.
foreign
[Music]
for sure
see I I don't I'm gonna say no okay and
I'll tell you why because I and it's a
close call I because
unfortunately I think if the the
if you're in 12 grades of public school
there's an indoctrination that you can't
undo I can protect a kid for a year in
the Middle East I mean through if you
really wanted to you could be check in
every day and I'm going to track you
with like this app and load you up with
Apple Air tags totally and it depends
you know are you in a are you in a nice
part of Beirut or Israel or something or
you you know and and if it was truly
like if you had to think about it you
could do something to say limit your
travel to here 12 years trying to
protect your kid in public school these
days with that agenda there's maybe one
year or two years you know a good
teacher or a good school but like you've
got a Traverse elementary middle and
high school yeah no way wait so you're
landing on it safer in the Middle East
yeah well that's what I thought I
answered in the long run it's more
dangerous to send your kid to public
school so you're saying it's more
dangerous so yes it's the public school
is more dangerous correct yeah yeah okay
oh yeah oh totally okay totally agree
absolutely yeah because yeah I mean I
just think
even from a physical standpoint I mean
you go to some like inner city schools
they can be pretty rough and tumble
maybe not quite like the streets I don't
even know that it's inner city yeah or
just anywhere the anecdotes yeah that
come back now about fights that break
out and the inability of of
Administrators and teachers to stop them
yeah
um totally and I mean like the videos
that I've seen online of some of these
middle school kids acting out and the
teacher's inability to stop them yeah
I I don't think it's limited now to to
Inner City I think yeah well into the
suburbs I totally agree and you just
think when kids minds are so malleable
when they're really really young if you
poison that you know you you hang around
that's what I'm saying though you can't
get this I mean 12 years of that and
again I'll give you three that you could
maybe protect yep but that's still nine
totally you're right in that public
school education yeah plus plus now you
know what the libs do is they say oh
you've got to go to kindergarten you've
got to go to pre-k you got to go to
pre-pre-k I mean they basically they
take you from the newborn Ward and they
throw you into an institution
people who get upset about nicknames are
real tight asses
hmm
oh yeah I mean yeah I don't think that
there should be any disagreement about
that what's your what's your favorite
nickname that you've had
Mr awesome
I I just got one the other day because I
said I was like I don't you don't want
to make up your own nickname obviously
so what fielded no no that was when they
called you in high school no no they
okay
she no one told me that I was I was in
uh I was I was asking these guys in the
chat I said what's a good nickname you
know and they have all this I said it's
kind of lame it's not cool this is what
they've landed on
Big Mike
so can I just and I'm not trying to cut
but who who's in this chat I well it
would um yeah it's Davey's Davey's
mother
um you know my I'm not even my wife
obviously no she would not talk it
sounds like a bunch of short people yeah
yeah it's really yeah Ben Ben Shapiro um
yeah you know just a lot of a big mike
over here you don't think that's fitting
yeah it is it's very fitting um
but yeah I I this is this explains a lot
though
okay what
yeah no it's your call I'm up you gotta
sleep I gotta slow down man I'm really
it's a lot Banning transgenderism in
public schools will Galvanize the left
more than it will encourage the base to
vote in 2024 assuming the conservative
okay so Banning transgenderism will help
the left more than the right
and just Banning it in the public
schools will help the left more than it
will help the ride
I say
no I think it I think it's a total
winner for the right oh total you I I
don't you don't okay I think the left
will go absolute Bonkers yeah in the
same way that roe has fired them up uh I
think that these guys it'll fire up
young people and I mean they they have
made this cause celeb so yeah it is
their it's their favorite issue right
it's the only one they want to talk
about right and the the way that they
have
presented this is is a human rights and
a civil rights issue so I I think that
they would look at this as a I mean look
at what they've done with don't say gay
you're literally talking about
kindergarten to third grade not talking
about sexuality I mean most kids don't
have a clue what you know half of the
body parts they have are and we're
saying don't talk about sexuality and
people went nuts Disney's putting out
statements and corporations are trying
to you know I mean so can if you
literally made a ban they'd go nuts
right right going up to grade 12 or
something yeah I suppose that's true
because I mean they called that Florida
Bill to don't say hey they also called
it the wait till eight
the idea that hey maybe just once how
about nine is nine I just the thing that
I find so funny is that like literally
as a parent you're you're sitting here
saying what would you tell me what you
know you can't put your kid on the rise
at an amusement park and you're going
but I'd like to talk to you about
sexuality yeah what about like when
you're done can we get into financial
planning I mean like what well you'll
you'll never get that in it in any
public schools
there's some tax consequences about what
we're talking about you're not ready to
hear this there's a lot of I mean
yeah no you're I think you're right in
the sense that you know I do a campus
tour with young Americas foundation and
we ask the schools
is there any Topic in particular that
you think Young conservatives really
want to have addressed
seven out of ten times the gender issue
so the gender issue you know how many
how many times you're going to talk
about how boys are boys and girls or
girls I guess you have to do it a number
of times it I mean it is crazy the idea
that the thing that I find funny is that
you have this juxtaposition where
it's all about science science science
and then you're like wait a second
but you don't want to of course yeah I I
no I'm absolutely amazed
January 6th we'll go down in history as
the modern day Gulf of Tonkin
hmm
wow there's a there are layers to that
question that I'm not sure Mr Davies
even fully appreciates
that's usually what he does yeah you
know he's like I hope these guys explain
what that means
guys what is the goal of Tonkin
I
yeah you got you got it right for me
yeah and same because I I just I don't I
think
there is a same kind of thing when I
sing before about the parents and Hunter
Biden like there is a sect
among the left that might believe that
um but I don't believe and actually I
would include a good chunk of the the
political media yeah uh but I don't
think beyond that that that that's
really accurate right
um so
if that if if you Quantified that
question with a little bit more
specificity then maybe but I I just
don't think the broader yeah and I do
Wonder because the thing that's
interesting is that when you talk about
historical dates
most of the time you can start to go
beyond a generation and say you know is
that going to be I don't know that
um
you know I do Wonder
what what the next generation is going
to be taught it may be in some textbooks
and it may be but I don't know that it's
going to resonate I mean you think I I
for me 911 is obviously very personal uh
I was very close to the Pentagon
um I you know serve in the military and
but it's amazing how many people have
lost the significance of that day right
yeah and that was a direct attack on the
United States thousands of Americans
killed a war that ensued for two decades
thousands more sort of epoch shaping and
yet and I go okay if you
lose the significance that amongst
a good chunk of the population and and
I'm not trying to but I just when you
start to talk to folks they still get it
but they may not have in in 20 years you
start to realize how that faded I do
think January 6 doesn't have the same
residence of course and I even this past
year on December 8th I looked down at
the clock I said oh yesterday was
December 7th and I did because my
grandfather fought in World War II I was
I was history buff always thought that
was a really important date and I
thought I just totally missed it this
year and then of course 911 even I mean
that one I I still pay attention to that
one but a lot of people don't uh really
acknowledge it and I think
because December 7th September 11th
if you had the audacity to add the date
January 6 to that it would be a punch
line of a very dark joke okay that's
absurd right and it's all and it already
kind of is a sort of punch January 6th
yeah I agree okay
I'm up I keep for every time it's me I
forget and you only had half of it so
far can I get a refill please let's do
I'm going to be speaking in cursive by
the end of this a big reason the US
government wants to ban Tick Tock is
because they're jealous that only China
can use it to spy on you and they can't
foreign
like
no you're right in how I would answer no
because they can spy on you all right
well but also
I
I don't think the people that are
Banning because it's members of Congress
um I don't
think there's a universal thought bubble
it spans different reasons although by
the way my best there's a Washington
Post Tech reporter
who tweeted out that it's unbelievable
that
and and I'm butchering it a little bit
but I'm not far off that basically he
said it's unbelievable that members of
Congress are about to ban Tick Tock and
most haven't used it and I was just like
well that's like saying that they're
about to like most people are going to
vote to go to war and they haven't fired
a missile I mean that's like the dumbest
thing I've ever heard yeah uh it's a
national security threat you don't go
let's go use it first
let me just make sure they've got all my
data and then okay good yeah look at it
okay now now ban it right um yeah so
yeah
um
I yeah I just don't give them that now
there may be some again but I don't
think that's the prevailing I do Wonder
too if part of part of the pressure to
ban it is a financial pressure from
Silicon Valley that doesn't want
competition oh that may be oh I'm sure
part of that but I will tell you the
funny thing about it is
if that is they're doing a bad job yeah
uh because I agree with you if I were
YouTube or snap or any of these folks I
would be trying to push them out a
little or egg it on yeah and I don't get
the sense that they are that's
interesting uh and I and which I would
if I were them I'd call on and be like
hey they're not yeah the Communists are
taking everything right yeah but the the
dirty Secret by the way that I thought
was hysterical three things
one when the CEO of Snapchat or Tick
Tock testified his talking points were
written by
a PR firm in DC that's closely tied to
to to Google right no no well to Google
but also to Anita Dunn she was a partner
there
um she it's a democratic firm tied to
Obama Anita Dunn his senior advisor that
she's on leave from that firm this is
right then secondly all of these media
organizations Playbook axios uh punch
bowl news they've all taken tick tock's
money in the form of sponsorships so you
wonder why you haven't had right right
it's and then the third thing that I
think is interesting is when Trump
didn't accept the Intel communities
warnings about Russia's interference
everyone on the left in the media went
nuts and said can you believe that Trump
will not accept the one 17 intelligence
agents he he is not accepting and then
when the FBI and the Intel communities
come out and say tick tock is the threat
to National Security that well you know
I mean it's not this isn't it
uh FBI yeah it's different you know
different I mean it's amazing that the F
they all freak out when it's the FBI but
when they all want to do it and it's
their base and they're all getting money
uh then it's like you know who you know
we'll investigate it who are they to say
anything you know it's amazing how it
plays out so that's what I think is
interesting about that
um this is interesting I have not seen a
card yet this is fascinating as I go to
read this there's highlighter on two
words wondering what's going on here a
national divorce is both that's one of
the highlighted words possible and
likely the other highlighted word so the
two highlighted words that we must
stress is that the national divorce is
both
possible which I would have highlighted
possible and like I don't know I don't
know somebody wasn't really focused with
their highlighters remedial highlighting
highlight that I don't know what kind of
like
classes the daily wires failed I'm gonna
have to talk to Jeremy about this but
the national divorce is both possible
and likely okay okay all right
um
yeah no it's just fake no it's a
separation
it's a trial separation to be honest
with you see what's missing from this is
an understanding of the prenup
that when the colonies were getting
together and this is something that
again is just missing in history because
there was a prenup and this is governing
a lot of what's happening right now and
that's why there's not going to be a
divorce because the cost of the
settlement would be too high and some of
the custody battles that would ensue yes
way too messy it's it's like you know
when couples who don't like each other
but they've been together for so long
they just kind of live Separate Lives
maybe it's under the same roof yeah
that's true now I wonder
one could if they really wanted to
pursue this a couple of mackerel
Snappers probably not big on divorce but
there could be an annulment
investigation one could look you know
there's just a revolution I was watching
this story the other day uh I believe
it's Oregon and Idaho about how one part
of one county is trying to join and I
was like I you know that in itself I
thought was fascinating but you start to
think of like a bunch of these states
where you think of like Texas right so
you've got Austin and then a bunch of of
more conservative parts around it even
think of Tennessee here right so you've
got Nashville and then a lot of the rest
of Tennessee Pennsylvania's got this
issue right even Virginia to some extent
but like a lot of these states so this
idea of a national divorce Georgia you
got Atlanta and the suburbs and then the
rest of Georgia yeah um I I don't think
it that's why it's not possible it's
funny because it's within the states
there's not there's very few that you've
got this I mean yes you've got your
California's New York's versus say a
Montana South Dakota but that's not you
right extricate these things yeah you
know during the cathar Crusade of I
believe 1206. is it 1206 or 1207 yeah I
I always it keeps me up at night I was
well anyway I don't want to call it out
but so the Catholics came down and they
there were these cathars you know these
crazy albigensians who were destroying
civilization and I forget which military
leader it was just as I forgot if it was
1206. and they go and they say all the
Catholics come out of the town but the
Catholics don't come out so the
Catholics and the cathars are mixed up
together
good the good civilization and the
people destroying civilization and uh so
he says well what do we do and the I
think true though it's become legendary
line is
uh kill them all God will sort it out
and I fear you know we're all kind of
jumbled up together here I don't want to
get lost in the shuffle
yeah I feel like sometimes there has to
be a little bit of a mess
and then things do sort like that you go
through a little bit of a family fight
for a while yeah
um maybe I'm wrong but I feel like if
you think about like the 1970s and
there's some periods in our nation's
history who knows but where things are a
little messy and then we eventually kind
of come out on the other side I'm hoping
that that's yeah I think I think that
happens it's just you know you you push
through we got The Seven Year Itch you
know we've got the uh 167 year I don't
know how old is the country yeah older
than that yeah it's a little older than
that okay speed round and it's my turn
okay
Michael Knowles would make it farther as
a press secretary than he would in a
dance competition not necessarily
because of his quick wit and knowledge
of the political process but rather
because he's so used to lying to his
producer about when he will arrive to
set and because his legs can barely take
him up the stairs much less keep an
eight count while holding onto a
professional dancer for life
I'm sensing a little tension in these
questions I just I'm gonna I went yes
early
um I because there was a little bit of a
tell in that
um uh I would say you did you got it
right I did okay good and uh yeah okay
foreign
[Laughter]
I don't know if the Men's Warehouse will
take it back
um
anyway the Second Amendment will be
abolished in our lifetime
it might be nullified though I fear um
see the thing is I agree like I don't
know the court may do something to to
your point no I don't think you're going
to actually get rid over I mean I don't
we it's such a hard time enacting
amendments yeah I I don't it would be
almost impossible to get rid of one yeah
so you could get a liberal court that
could interpret it in such a way that
would reverse right interpretations of
it but I don't see AP yeah I could say
the sort of well the penumbras of the
emanations of the penumbras say you know
they met us they meant a squirt gun or
something exactly
strongest candidate for the Democrats in
2024 would be Michelle Obama this of
course could be because of all the lib
boxes checked Michelle never
accomplished anything meaningful
politically virtue signals on every
topic would only
prep was only proud to be an American
when they gained power and would I'm not
reading this I'm not
see this is interesting because I don't
know enough about there are a lot of
people who share this okay because I
don't want it there's one do you know
the thing that's written here that no I
don't I don't I it but it says and would
and would be the first trans woman of
color to run for president but then it
says here due to YouTube rules make your
guess but do not verbally confirm if the
other person guessed correctly give only
an ambiguous non-verbal confirmation
I've actually lost the question yeah
good but here's what I would just say
here here's what I would just say on
this I I think that just on the on the
first part of this Michelle I I've heard
enough people Michelle Obama will never
run for president she's never wanted to
run for president she's expressed that
over and over again and I I find people
on the right who talk about this to just
lack an understanding of
of of how the not this is the process
but I mean she's not going to get
drafted into doing this yeah I I totally
agree I'm glad we didn't even move those
classes yes because I because people
they don't understand if you've ever
seen a presidential race even somewhat
like
at a distance but with any kind of
intimacy you know it's
a brutal miserable right well that's the
thing yeah I mean it consumes two years
of my life and also you have I mean this
is the thing on any office you have to
want to do it when people say I'm trying
to talk so-and-so into running yeah you
can't for any office class president you
don't talk someone in Mitch Daniels this
is a dumb question okay people who shame
men for being short are nothing more
than hype supremacists I it's super
um
uh yeah like it's pretty obvious yeah
it's an evil bigotry yeah and it should
be a rabbit what do you call that the
soft bigotry of Love yeah the the short
bigotry yeah this is
by the way Sean when you said this is a
stupid question you we could apply that
to the whole game to every single moment
of the game this I just I feel bad for I
mean I get the work requirement
we haven't been using zip recruiter
recently we've been using a stick that
we throw outside and find fair enough uh
Rhonda Santos will be the Republican
nominee in 2024.
foreign
[Music]
you waited for me I did
you you're correct you're incorrect okay
yeah I couldn't well so here's the thing
is it possible sure I'm not really
anything but but I've approached this
from a uh
a place of logic and the logic is that
every state has a threshold right a
minimum threshold that you have to get
in a caucus in the primary the minimum
has has always been 10 some as high as
20 percent that's part of the reason
Trump won in 2016. yeah meaning so if
you're in Iowa New Hampshire South
Carolina whatever if you don't get X
percent and like I said minimum is
usually 10 then you get no delegates
yeah so right now Trump and DeSantis are
the only two people who would even
qualify under the 2016 rules for any
delegates
Trump has been actually going around
working these State parties to raise
their threshold and do this Trump is
going to have a six-month Head Start he
also has two cycles of data on every
Republican voter and a ton more
fundraising Pro prowess so for those
reasons the the ability to say I'm going
to run a mile and give you a a you know
one lap Head Start is just a huge
Advantage you know the only reason I I
hedged a little bit here and thought you
might say yes is just because you know
the the GOP kind of powers that be
you've worked around them you know and
it seemed to me a lot of the established
institutional powers on the right have
been increasingly Pro DeSantis I didn't
know if that was yeah but I agree that's
why I'm saying I don't I don't rule it
out yeah right so so I'll give you my
quick scenario I think if if DeSantis
were to put all his chips in Iowa or New
Hampshire and strike a knockout blow
yeah my knockout blow I mean I think if
you if you beat the former president
in one of those two states by three four
five percent
I think that's a very significant uh
hurdle to then overcome if you're Trump
uh so and then it would set off a series
of of you know uh reconfiguration yeah
that but but I I think that that's what
it would take and that's a big right big
you know obstacle to overcome
so I think it's possible but I just
don't think it's likely we've got a ways
to go there's a lot more that can happen
but again so I'm not ruling anything out
I'm not saying it's but it is trumps to
lose yeah I agree I totally agree okay
last question no this is yours oh yeah
okay that's what I'm the guest but that
was you know I mean
okay
roughly 50 of democratic congressmen
are closet Communists basically Senator
McCarthy was right
he was talking about the state
department first of all but and he
well okay how are we gonna answer are we
going to answer
based on this very poorly random
question are we going to answer based on
the congressman or the state department
bureaucracy I think it's I think clearly
the intent of the question yes is
members of Congress yeah okay okay
again I'm doing the analysis here I
think that you have to look at the
current so you have
214 14.
ish I'm trying to do the math so that
gets you I was going to say 15.
it's like that but it's still you're
looking at 107 yeah
you think I'm going to say the commies
half of them yeah
are you I I well I was gonna say no I
don't know now you're kind of convincing
me no I I don't think they're companies
did I get this right by the way you
think they are coming no I think that
under the current math yeah that I I
probably think a third yeah yeah right I
mean there there are like actual a valid
socialists yes people I just think for
most of them it's not that they're con
it's kind of like some people think the
devil is is under every Rock You know
it's like the devil's real demons are
real but they're not under every single
Rock everywhere it's like it's like a
third of the rocks and they're
definitely under the pyramids but the
the when the Democrats I think yes some
of them are a valid socialists and
Communists right most of them are just
Libs right you know and that's bad too
now I do think it's evolving that way I
do think that more and more each cycle
are moving in a way that finds socialism
an acceptable thing and don't think that
that's wrong yeah but I don't know that
we're there yet and I think part of it
is that because you've got so many older
members of Congress that are all
old-school blue blood type Dems
um that they're they're not there yet
but as they're getting replaced with the
new younger ones absolutely well as as
that moves in that direction as as we
move toward this national uh I don't
know what is it separation or these
communities or yeah then we'll look
forward to as that approaches filling
this with something A Little Bit
Stronger Yeah in the meantime though
go get this book bravebooks.com
bravebooks.com the parrots go bananas
nice fruity drinks for a fruit it
actually it matches
we've been very harsh on the producers
in this episode yeah but that's very
yeah I I assume that was like yeah it's
the only compliment they're ever getting
on the show we'll see you next time on
yes or no
[Music]
oh